the All Souls
choir that's an important
song uh for your religious edification
and your political edification borrowing
words from Stacy Abrams Melissa duny and
Ida B Wells coming to a
leftist church community near you take
it
[Music]
away
right we live in the right
our mights
depend on where we
were
our on how
[Music]
our
he matches our gender our rights depend
the lawers we
can
right on whe the criminal jce
[Music]
system hold on
of the last one's true your rights
actually do depend whether or not you've
been convicted of certain crimes and if
you have then you do actually forfeit
some rights yeah and if your ID will
generally match your gender something
would have had to go seriously wrong for
you know your big Husky Hank shows up to
the ID place and they list you as a
woman on your ID that all right
depend this is being sung by the All
Souls choir because there was always a
relation between church and state
there's always a relation between the
political order and religion it's an old
it's an older clip this clip is from I
think a year ago maybe even a little bit
more than a year ago expect more of this
expect forget about this being sung in
some room and going viral on Twitter
there are going to be couldn't you just
see the military parades going by in the
new Rainbow regime where you've got the
the dictator some kind of androgynous
dictator just standing there upright
making some weirdo salute and then just
rainbow tanks go by all
right because all politics ultimately is
theological and uh this this kind of
propaganda seeps in
everywhere you know we we make fun of
the North Korean crazy Communist Regime
for brainwashing people and the people
behaving in this totally bizarre
way conservative members of Congress
screaming Furious about white privilege
and girl bosses not being able to speak
enough I wonder
how how's the brainwashing going here
how's the how's the regime change going
here maybe maybe a cou d'a really has
taken place I don't think it was the
horn hat guy that let it there is a cou
d'a occurring right now in Poland here's
the headline this is out of Politico the
European edition of Politico
police polish police arrest members of
parliament as Tusk versus Duda rule of
law battle heats up so this is a rule of
law battle according to Politico between
the Prime Minister and the president
Poland's new government faces a huge
struggle to unravel eight years of rule
by the Nationalist pis party so there
was a right-wing government in Poland
and then the leftwing government takes
power and what do they do immediately
what they do is they disband the public
media they suppress the media this if it
were to have happened under a right-wing
government you would hear calls for un
peacekeepers to show up you we would
hear that this was the total dismantling
of democracy in the country in fact
that's what you did hear when Hungarian
prime minister Victor Orban instituted
relatively modest reforms of the press
in Hungary happens in Poland they just
disband the entire public media and and
what do the liberal do they say this is
a threat to democracy no you know what
they they cheer it they say well this is
so good this is a restoration of
democracy then the piece goes
on now you've got cops invading the
presidential Palace to arrest members of
parliament that's bad that's a cou d'
Tha is that well not according to
Politico in a dramatic escalation of
Poland's battle to restore rule of
law the police entered the country's
presidential Palace on Tuesday evening
and took two members of parliament into
custody who had been hiding under the
protection of President Andre Duda after
being sentenced to prison for terms for
abuses of
power this is the the battle to restore
rule of law and the way that we're going
to restore rule of law is we're going to
ban the press and we're going to invade
the presidential Palace and we're going
to arrest members of parliament that's
how we're going to does that sound like
restoring rule of
law doesn't to me it sounds like totally
upending the rule of
law but this is because one man's
insurrectionist is another man's
defender of democracy you know that
phrase the libs always say they say one
man's Freedom Fighter is another man's
terrorist and they they say this to blur
the distinction between terrorists and
Freedom Fighters to say well from from
our perspective you know these jihadis
in the Middle East they're terrorists
but from their perspective they're
Freedom
Fighters but as with the libs always
trying to blur distinctions distinctions
between men women distinctions between
one country and another country it's
just totally bogus because terrorism has
a meaning terrorism is defined in large
part by whether or not you target
civilians to achieve political ends
that's a really basic definition of
terrorism and you can measure that you
can say are people targeting civilians
to achieve political ends okay well that
would be an act of terrorism same
here is a
government um contradicting what the
people want what the People Express is
the government uh upending established
norms and traditions and even
laws if so that's not very Democratic is
it you know that in Colorado they say
that to defend democracy we need to
prevent the people from voting for
Donald Trump who's the single most
popular candidate in the presidential
race that just can't be true it's only
true if you if you redefine democracy to
be deprived of all of its
meaning it's a reminder I'm I'm not just
here complaining about what's going on
in Eastern Europe without a fact I know
that that whatever we say about this is
not going to affect what happens and the
way that there is a couet in in Poland
but it's just a reminder you're going to
hear a lot about insurrections and couet
and blah blah blah for the next 12
months you got to try to pull yourself
out of that bubble you got to try to
pull yourself out of the fish tank you
know the water in which we Little
Fishies are swimming you gotta you've
got to try to get some perspective here
and recognize that the media are not
neutral that the system of laws in our
civil government they're not Eternal
they're changing they're always kind of
changing jurist Prudence the way that we
interpret the law that's changing a lot
too the language that we use it's not
totally objective and it's not Eternal
it's constantly being manipulated to to
scramble up our brains and to change the
way that we perceive the world and when
they huff and puff and scream and they
say all the anyone who supports the
Conservative candidate they're just
upending democracy I might listen I
might not be a republican but I want
there to be a strong Republican party in
this country just not that kind of
Republican not the kind of Republican
it's just
bogus it's just manipulative nonsense
and we've got to be able to see that and
stand firm and and if we're at the point
right now where the Republican the
conservative members of Congress are
just blindly belching up leftwing
talking points they don't they have no
idea even what they're saying it's going
to be very very difficult to gain that
kind of perspective and to fight back
man what a great clip that was now hold
up hold up hold up hold up all my fellas
who be saying we soft ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time